you
[Music]
so hello everyone I am Prashant na maker
so here i am representing gaia smart
cities so we are a small start-up in a
IOT space so what we are doing in
Microsoft we are trying to develop
something speech recognizer ation on the
small footprint devices on the edge
itself we will try to debug everything
and on the edge itself we will try to
spot the keywords with a low footprint
ramps so here is what we have proposed
as an objective so the main objective
which we had is that we will be putting
all the machine learning codes on the
small footprint devices which has having
a extremely low low for low ram size and
apart from this we are using the audio
input mics so we have to take them
inputs from the mic we have to process
that we have to put that into the RAM
all the processing should happen in less
than 100 milliseconds so we will need a
fast computing means the model site
should be less of the machine learnings
so other than that we will reduce the
number of computation requires 2 also we
will be focusing on the accuracy what we
can get and what we can achieve more so
this where we plan in and what are the
tangible outcomes we got in 1 month of
time are we have developed one generic
tool what that tool do is you just have
to pass the checkpoints file like the
tensorflow model file to it it will just
create micro microcontroller independent
libraries that is dot e dot H files that
is C library files you can directly port
that on to the microcontroller thing so
other than that we have developed our
own machine learning libraries for the
cortex m4 and cortex m7 for the Alice TM
and the Fajr NN also for GRU thing so in
1 month of time we have almost 60
comparative experiment on different
recurrent neural network models other
than that we have Android app to gather
the data set so as currently we are
using the Google 7 and Google 30 data
set for our models we will be
moving to some of the Indian languages
so if I we have worked on the different
ml models are the DSC NN g ru l s TM g r
NN and fajr n and with low rank so this
is the microcontroller we will be using
for our development purpose the RAM size
is either spoke is 128 KB of Rama Ram
and Phi 1 2 KB of flash it is operating
at a CPU speed of 180 megahertz and same
thing we have developed for MCM for also
n m7 also we are using the the main main
reason of using the m4 & m7 was it is
having an impedance truck sure support
and some of the layer neural network
libraries are supported so for the DSP
library we are using for the dot product
and the dot products addition
subtraction vector copy and some of the
FFT things also we are storing the wav
files in the dot s format for the so
offline training and all and we will be
saving the Hamming frames and all in the
dot H file itself
so I will be passing the mic to Sneha
next I will be taking you all to the
workflow of qubit spotting so basically
the data which we have is audio so we
cannot directly send the audio to the
neural network to get the predictions so
first of all we need to extract some
features out of the audio and here we
are doing that you can see there are
speech free speech signals there we are
processing them to get the speech
features and then putting those features
into the neural network the neural
network thus gives us the predictions of
the audio for this problem set we have
used the data set which was given by
Google that is called Google speech
commands and it has 30 key words like
yes no it has a background noise files
also with it
we have trained the model for 30 class
and 7 class problem also the Train test
and validation set split was given in
the dataset itself so the features we
have
like extracted a logarithm of the
male-male scale filter filter banks
these are extracted for one second audio
so we get a mouth feature matrix of
dimension 99 cross 32 the data set is
also normalized with the mean and
standard deviation of the training data
set next
these are the models that we are using
we are using basic RNN models I'm sure
you all are well aware of what is a
tenon model so I would not go that much
into it we're using lsdm and fast gr NN
fast these two other like versions of
different versions of RN n so we have
trained three different models LST fast
gr inin and fast gr inin with low rank
now we have trained more than 60 models
with different classes optimizers and
hidden states learning rates here are
some of our results that you can see we
have the model learning rate optimizers
batch size ebooks weight size accuracy
and all these things then after like
doing all these experiments we have
finally reached onto one of the models
which are which we decided to be
deployed on the microcontroller the
model deployed has had falling
specifications the it was a seven class
model with 16 hidden States accuracy of
91 point one percent and weight size of
three point six KB
it was with background noise and
quantized nonlinearities next I would
like to call upon sugar uh hi my name is
Shubham and so now we have trained our
models intensive flow so the important
thing that we want to do is we want to
get all these models on to our
microcontroller so the first thing that
we need to do is we need to somehow
convert the whole of the the tensorflow
models into a format that is recognized
by C so for that particular purpose we
decided to generate we decided to create
a tool that is Auto generate the
dot H files for us that will contain all
the important information of the models
like the hidden weights the input the
dense layer the dense bias and all or
another information apart from that we
also populated our dot H file with some
constants which were very critical for
your processing such as the filter banks
Hamming window etc so something that we
would like to we observe during this
during the course of the workshop was
that there the filter Bank matrix was
found to be sparse and in the sparsity
we observed a very unique pattern that
actually allowed us to exploit it so the
pattern that we observed was something
like this so initially the there were
some zeros then there were some nonzero
elements and then they were there were
more zeros so what is actually happening
was we had a continuous length of
nonzero elements and which were preceded
and succeeded by zeros so now this kind
of observation made us think how let's
say let's let's just compute let's just
see how many nonzero elements we have in
this whole matrix so the results that we
found look quite surprising so we used
as you can see that the the matrix the
entire matrix is 32 cross 257 which
turns out to be around 8000 224 total
number of elements in the matrix but in
the whole matrix we found that there
were only 458 nonzero elements now that
kind of goddess to thinking like if we
are multiplying this matrix with another
matrix of 257 then we have to kind of
perform for the whole matrix you have to
perform around eight thousand two
hundred and twenty-four computations
instead why that is that was majorly
because we were mult we were doing a lot
of zero multiplications so instead of
that we said why can't we represent this
in another format and Guth do only for
58 multiplications corresponding to the
nonzero elements and part of it after
kind of thinking about how we could do
this we came up with this particular
representation that we
just store the length of the nor the
length of the nonzero elements of each
row the column index at which the
nonzero elements start and all that
nonzero elements as a single array of
458 elements so initially as you can see
we were taking eight thousand two
hundred and twenty-four we were storing
eight thousand two hundred and twenty
four elements for the filter banks but
with this kind of representation we just
have around five hundred elements
500-foot floating point numbers so an
estimate of the sizes like the first
model had each as each floating-point
number is four bytes it would have
occupied 32 KB of Flash
but with this kind of representation we
got we occupied only two KB's of Flash
and secondly the computations were much
more faster and indeed this flowed out
to be very beneficial to us because we
were using this multiplication every 10
milliseconds so an estimate of how much
time got decreased was initially our a
model that we had done without using any
kind of these without using any of these
optimizations took around 1.5 eight
seconds analyst TM model but when we use
when we shifted to a faster RNN model
and we performed this optimization and
several other optimizations we brought
down the time or 289 milliseconds so
there was a huge gain for us by using
this kind of representation of matrix so
I would like to hand over the mic to
Yosh and he'll explain the whole
pipeline in some day yeah thank you now
here we have received a dot H file now
II need to do the predictions in the
microcontroller we were having a DMA
buffer of 20 millisecond 20 milliseconds
it can store the audio sample of 20
millisecond over there now here we have
mains MEMS microphone where from where
we get the PCM values and we store it in
our DMA buffer now in this DMA buffer it
fails the first 10 millisecond it gives
us a half transfer callback and we keep
this keep that 10 millisecond wait 10
millisecond audio in our 30 millisecond
buffer which is for feature extraction
we have made that 30 millisecond buffer
because we need 25 millisecond of window
so as to extract the features and after
that it when it passes that 10
millisecond it keeps on updating this
DMA buffer miss while we transfer the
date out to over 30 millisecond buffer
it keeps on updating the 10 to 20
millisecond in this DMA buffer and after
completing this 10 to 20 millisecond it
for use a full transfer callback and I
passed it that 10 to 20 millisecond over
there and similarly for 20 to 30 after I
filled that 30 millisecond buffer window
over there
I used that 24 25 millisecond window to
extract the features and I get 32 log
Milbank filter and any shell eyes and if
that fuzzy our end layer with 16 hidden
units with zeros and this is the first
time frame of the Orang layer since we
are using 0 to 25 millisecond and this
is the input vector and this is the
previous hidden states that we get and
we compute the next hidden units for
next fuzzier and gate and I copy those
weights over there and we need 8 10
milliseconds right over here so I shift
that 30 millisecond buffer and the next
30 to 40 millisecond audio we take it
from that DMA buffer and again store it
in our 30 millisecond buffer and again
extract the mel filter bank and again do
the same for the second time frame of
the Henley and we do it for 99 steps
since we have trained our model on one
second one second audio which has 99
frames of 25 millisecond with 10 seconds
right okay here we are firing 24 gr n
layers and computing the predictions
over here I will show you how it is
working like if I give the 2 second
audio over there I initialize the first
year and layer at the start and I
compute that first year and layer and I
get the prediction like 6 I have got the
prediction maximum of the probabilities
of the softmax that we obtain after
applying the densely and I store it in a
buffer the buffer is called ten previous
predictions like it will store the
previous ten predictions in that buffer
over there and here I initialized the
second first year and layer after fifty
milliseconds like the first fuzzier and
layer is from zero second to one second
the second fuzzy layer is from 50
millisecond to one second 50
milliseconds and again do the
predictions over here and I keep it keep
that data in that in the in my buffer
which has twenty previous predictions
and I'd do the same again and again and
again and when I receive since here we
have like five we have five times
predicted three over here so like it has
it calculates the frequency how many
times a particular particular keyword
has been predicted if it goes more than
five times then it predicts that
particular keyword and it shows the
output and we do it for twenty first we
apply twenty Faustian layers over here
like that twenty five twenty thousand
layer is just starting just before one
mil one second and ending just before
the second second second sorry and when
the one second is completed I again
reinitialize the first first year in
layer and I again start it started to
compute for the prediction hello I'm
Sheena Joe so as we already discussed
that we are converting the ckp T files
to dot H files so that they can be fed
into the microcontroller and then used
for the further processing this is the
tool that would help us to do it first
all that you need to do is just upload
the checkpoint files and the
corresponding me and under standard
deviation files so in the background
these files they get uploaded into the
ashore blob and then the file starts
executing which converts those files
into the dot H file and it gets again
uploaded into another as your block so
once this process is done you will be
navigated to another page which in this
space by clicking the download you would
be allowed to download
the weights file that is generated in
and put in the azure block to your local
system and from this you can feed it
into the microcontroller the best part
is this whole tool it can be used in any
microcontroller that is it is
independent of any microcontroller um
that is because it uses the only basic
integer data types so you can use this
this tool for any other microcontroller
right now it works only for the fast grn
and lsdm but again you can extend it to
any other model so in this three weeks
we had a chance as she is now already
mentioned to work with our own 60 models
we have trained the models using the
ELISA TM fast gr inin and fast urine and
low rank and each of which we have
trained with the 30 class and the
servant class and again each of those
we've trained it with background noise
and without background noise so we had
some observations some of them are
pretty evident that is the seventh class
accuracies are better than the 30 class
and the accuracies of without background
noise models are better than the width
background noise so other one is the
fast gr n low rank model for the higher
number of hidden states that is for 128
hidden states it worked very well I mean
it gave us the better accuracy but when
we were using it for the 16 hidden
States it kind of gave us a little less
accuracy so we had to narrow down
between the false gr NN and Ellis tiem
and for the 30 and we were only keen on
using the 16 16 hidden states with
background noise model so for the 30
class with background noise model
falsity irenan has given us the better
accuracy but when we were using the 7
class with background noise the ellis
tiem is slightly given as the better
accuracy czar on maybe 1% higher or less
than 1% higher but considering the model
size we had to choose the fast gr n n
model the fast gr in an model is three
times smaller than that of the LST model
because we we have to fit this in a
constrained device features a fast your
inin model and we have used the
quantized nonlinearities of farad so
finally we had a model size of around
3.6 KB with ninety 1.1 percent accuracy
and apart from that we had some other
observations like initially we use the
panitch and the sigmoid functions but
while computing them on the
microcontroller it took a lot of time
for the computations but when we started
using the quantized nonlinearities
because they use only a basic functions
like minimum and maximum the computation
time kind of decreased and while
training the models when we were using
the quantized once the atom optimizer
worked well for us and when we use the
normal usual functions the momentum
optimizer worked well also initially we
started using the log functions but
because it takes the input as the double
and we were providing it with the fluid
there was this type promotion that was
happening which took a lot of time for
the computations but when we switch to
the log of function
it helped us with the computation time
and also while training we have noticed
that after certain epochs the last kind
of spiked up so to overcome that after
certain number of epochs we have half an
hour learning rate and we validated the
Microsoft's fast iranian model in real
time on our microcontroller which has a
single processor I would like to give it
to the tensor I mean the motivation that
we built was extremely small footprint
low no computation battery has to last
for about six months no connectivity and
I mean you know what Alexa does we
wanted to do completely on the edge and
those are the motivations and then we
realized that it could be it could also
solve these problems of security of
privacy connectivity and power and
that's what that's what we have extended
it to in addition the models that we
built the framework that we built is
easily scalable across use cases so
while today we're doing it for sixty six
watts you're doing it for a certain
number of one particular sector we
believe with the framework that we have
it can replicate easily and also what we
have seen I mean in fact that's the
Soviet the microcontroller using as an
AR mm4 it's a very small footprint it's
got 180 it's a 180 megahertz
with 256 KB in that we get the power
that it consumes just 89 micro amperes
for every computation for per megahertz
computation and right now with what we
have Dell
we just need eighty nine milliseconds
for one second of speech analysis so
faster than you speak I think we can
analyze the the whole what are you
trying to say and this is the another
three point six KB as you know the team
mentioned earlier without monetization
speed to contrary quantize it comes to
less than one point one point not KB
this now so that's the stm32 this is the
the azure IOT sphere that's the that's
the controller which has about 500
megahertz it's at the RM a7
it's superior far superior in terms of
computation power we believe if we
increase the number of word size even to
a hundred and if you don't quantize we
can actually get a file size of not know
model size and not not more than 9.5 KB
and this actually exceeds the number of
use cases that we can apply it to we're
trying to extend it to services in
retail hospitality services and
industrial manufacturing as well pretty
much which doesn't require connectivity
or no or power even I mean these are
number of use cases that we believe we
can move fast even panic detection in
gabs
feedback you know usage in cities all of
that is baby we can this one I want to
talk about yesterday I met from Intel
and they have a smart home application
which they don't want it to be it they
want it to be lightly connected to the
Internet they want a lot of processing
on the edge itself they don't want for
every if for every analyst is I can like
does they don't wanna contact the server
and they believe this can be a good use
case similarly in the connected car I
mean just for starting a car they wanna
move where the start button and if we
can give them the ability to start just
by saying talking and the analyst is and
the foot and the fingerprint I mean the
Wiseman can be analyzed on the edge I
think it solves a lot of problems for a
lot of people connectivity security what
we're trying to do is increase the
number of languages in fact we built
this model to actually replicate across
languages we have to work on false
positives we have seen over false
positives right now we want to extend it
to more use cases we wanna design use
case in fact you see the demo that we
have it's a pretty small footprint thing
with power think or I think on a single
double-a battery we think it can last
for about two months with at least a
thousand I and usage per day we want to
be the trials we also want to add in a
speaker to it
and you have one model now we're just
doing speech recognition we would like
to do with gender detection sentiment
analysis also the footprint shouldn't
exceed so much I'll end with this and
well without without ending I can't can
do it without thanking the Microsoft
team uh that there
Harsha pratik bridge yesterday who
helped us solve you know the real-time
voice problem we're doing everything off
off the off the drive but we did the
real-time just last night we had help
from bridge
Satish Chris all of them thank you so
much and without further ado I'll call
pressure on to give you a demo ok so
meanwhile I can give a demo on the small
kid so this is a stm32 m4
microcontroller so it is having a ram
size of 128 KB so we have we are having
the biggest challenge that to take the
audio real-time to process that pretty
prediction everything we have to do in
the small amount of time so I will be
giving the demo on that so you can see
that for prediction we are just for
prototyping we are using the LEDs to
display so here if I say yes this LED
should bring this LED will be
continuously blinking just to show that
it is on and if I say no it should blink
down and similarly for others
so one thing we have just yesterday
night we have cracked this actually
yesterday it became so ok I will give
the demo
yes and so now we will focus on the
other parts also the size is what is
really exciting the size and the power
consumption all this in 89 milliseconds
is what we can achieve this was one
thing was the sparsity matrix what the
male banc filter and all he talked about
previously it was taking some around
8,000 computations so after that we
observe that we don't actually need that
much computations we have reduced to
around 450 or something and other than
that some DSP instruction sites
[Music]
ah no need we can show you I think
there's a couple things we need crack
before that one is the false positives
we need to reduce false positives we'd
like to increase the languages because
in India the the language is the first
use case it would be even the Airports
Authority of India we've got 32 airports
signed up for this or it to be in the
first part machine where it's toilets
and the thing with toilets is people
want to come out and press a button they
because they think it's dirty so they'd
rather say something then press a button
and that's why speech came in I mean
voice came in I mean voice in fact they
wanted a sentiment analysis too and we
have done sentiment analysis doesn't
have an an illicit but not I mean the
footprint is too small to do today and
we couldn't crack it but these are
requirements are coming from the market
it's not a we haven't invented them
[Music]
honestly no
we haven't thought about that but we
have thought about is of one person
giving multiple feedbacks and there we
on the Qualcomm I mean on the Snapdragon
which is got a high processing so we've
analyzed the speech print and try to
detect duplicates there we haven't done
it on this because of the well of the
size but I was you we can work out how
to detect duplicates on in the voice
print you know neato who it is by Justin
we hope I Oh tea spear has some kind of
security checks on that
alright this is a monic so we haven't
studied artists aerial attacks I doubt
we would be able to cope with that
rotate surreal attacks but I think we
get some robustness to sensor noise so
if your sensor is not very good quality
and because of the quantization etcetera
it might be robust to that but I doubt
we would be able to overcome so if we
move the problem away and handle it
differently so the system works by
proximity if the whole system can work
because of proximity you can put
approximately sense and then make it
active only when you proc when you're
close to it probably do away with that
unless somebody comes close with the you
know so there are possibly other ways to
offset that thing saying that don't make
it don't switch it on
in fact that helps us a power to don't
make the system active without you know
somebody coming close interesting
feedback and a simple proximity sensor
can help us solve that sure so if you
have 100 hundreds of kilobytes of RAM
and flash available do you really care
whether the model is one kilo bytes or
20 kilobyte can you say a little bit
about like how much space are you going
to advocate for this RNN or lsdm amongst
all the other things you need to also
fit on to the microcontroller so I
missed a bit of your presentation so
perhaps you already spoke about this so
maybe more than Ram your battery
consumption might be more of an issue so
did you test whether in lsdm this is a
fast urine and how much was the
consumption how much was the
computational cost on the battery
requirement that priority were C V so we
calculated hypothetically we just didn't
do experiment we didn't have the
opportunity to experimentally that's one
number two the size does matter if you
are actually looking at trying to
increase the feature set or other
functionality I mean as we spoke some
time back if you try to do sentiment
analysis or if you try to do gender
detection or if you try to do age
detection of the person who's talking
whether these are all things that can
come
and if you can extend it to include all
these I guess size does matter
but let's not speak hypothetically for
your concrete application how much space
do you have reserved or how much space
have you got allocated or earmarked for
the Orang an oralist IAM this
microcontroller has 128 kb ram and for
this entire application it consumes 123
KB of entire RAM for complete
computation prediction and taking in the
input data actually the most of the
memory is going for that 10 milliseconds
or Ihnen will fit on the flash right you
won't have gotten in an ramesseum no no
but we need to have some you need to
have some matrix over here in the RAM so
as to take the weights from the weights
from the flash so as to compute it in
the RAM over here sorry I didn't follow
but maybe I will take this offline with
you
it's not your day